right so welcome everyone to the second
lecture uh today and actually the last
lecture during the boot camp and Marcelo
Arenas will talk about sampling uh and I
promise you you will not be disappointed
thank you so welcome to the last session
so today I'm going to talk about
sampling in query evaluation so let me
start by giving you what is the goal of
this tutorial what we would like to do
here
first is well to show some fundamental
problems that motivate the use of
sampling databases there is a reason why
these techniques have been studied in
this area so I would like to give you
some intuition behind this
why these techniques are are being used
um
explain the difficulties Behind these
problems why do we need sample
techniques where we cannot solve this by
using some I mean what you could
consider like I mean usual techniques uh
show some tools that I use to do
something in this context and this is
kind of the difficult part because
probably this is going to look like a
random sample of sampling techniques
it's very difficult way too many
techniques actually so I will try to
give you some overview of some of them
hopefully you will learn something I I'm
apparently I meant that I'm sure there
is a lot of people here that knows way
more than me about these things actually
but hopefully some of you will learn
something about these techniques uh
explain how these tools can be used to
provide solution to the problems that
are our motivating problems and
particular well partial Solutions in
some cases
and I would say finally convince the
oldest audience that there are
interesting open problems in the area
hopefully and also that sampling tools
could be very useful right not only to
be used in these problems but in in
other type of problems
okay so let me start with the motivation
and I'm going to talk about three
related problems the first problem is
it's query optimization this is a very
basic problem right so in this case we
would like to compute the answer to this
query this is a join the usual I mean
querying databases in this case we have
well rsmt this is the notation I'm going
to be using these are the name of the
attribute so here we are doing the
natural join so we have a common
attribute B here right yeah
yeah okay so we want to compute the
answer to this query so what the system
do the data management system do is to
they think about query plans I mean how
to evaluate this given that this joint
operation is associative and is
commutative right so for example they
say okay we could do something like this
first compute The Joint of R and S and
then compute the joint with t but we
have other alternative we could start
first by doing the join between s and t
or we can use a commutative and say okay
why don't we do R joint T and then s
right and this gives right to different
uh trees actually you can think of this
as the three that represents the
evaluation of the query right so for
example in this case we are saying okay
we're going to start with this joint
from for S R and S and then we are going
to do the join with uh for with t right
an important thing here is that these
different plants can have different
costs and what the system wants to do is
to try to find the optimal one right the
one with the lowest cost and this could
be very difficult difficult because you
you are not allowed to I mean answer the
query using each one of these plans to
know which one is the optimal that will
be way too expensive right so you need
to do some sort of estimation right to
to to uh try to estimate as fast as
possible which one of this plan is the
is the best one so let me show you an
example so just a simple example so
suppose that we have this relation here
you see that here we are going to do the
join so here we have uh for this value 4
here we have lots of tablet we have n
tuples for the value two we only have
one Tuple but then when we take a look
at at s actually we see that well we're
doing the join in the B attribute so for
Value two we have only one table but for
value four we also have n Tuple so we
are going to produce n square tapos
right but at the end actually if you
think about the joint that we're
Computing since we are joining on the C
attribute the only value that we can
join is this zero here right so all the
tabs that we're going that we could
produce by using this value for are not
going to be using the answer so the
plants could have really different cost
right if you think about this plan so
which was the first one the first one
say okay start by joining these two and
you're going to produce this this table
that has n square plus one tuples right
a bit a really big uh yeah intermediate
results and then you are going to
compute the answer which only have one
tab right so this is really expensive
you think about that and the other plan
was going to be much more cheaper right
if you think about this plan so when we
start from from these two tables
actually so here you do the join and
you're realizing me and we're realizing
immediately that you can only join this
value 0 here with the value 0 here right
and then you just compute this Tuple
here I'm going to do you do the join
here you're going to compute just this
double here so it's a it's like an
extreme example but it shows you
actually that intermediate results could
be quite different
okay so you can have the same problem
you start adding operators in this talk
I'm going to consider join selection and
projection so for example if you add
here selection and here we are saying we
want to select all the tuples where the
value of the attitude would be is equal
to four right so again we can have
different plans but here things start
getting a bit more complicated because
you can push selection into the relation
so you are going to have different
Alternatives and again actually
different plants can give you really
different results so let's look at the
previous example again so if you have
something like this where we have the
selection at the very end we are going
to compute this large relation with N
squared tuples and then we do the join
and we just have one table and when we
say select with b equal to four you
realize that the the result is empty
right but you did it at the very end so
if you change this plan by by something
like this actually right when you start
doing the selection you put you push the
selection to the relations when you do
this this selection you get you get this
relation here I'm going to do the join
actually since we are joining the C
attribute you immediately realize that
this is empty so and at the end you are
going to have an empty result right so
this is a much better plan than the
other one
so uh what do we need to do here is to
do cardinality estimation right so to
compare query plants we need to uh we
need estimations of the cardinality of
the intermediate result that's what we
would like to do and such estimations
should be computed efficiently actually
very efficiently right we what we try to
do here is to say okay these are
different plants these are the costs of
this plant this is the optimal one and
and and this we have to do it when we
are trying to compute the answer to the
query right so this is a cost that we
have to add to the cost of answering the
query so better to do this as fast as
possible so this is one uh reason to uh
or one reason why sampling technique
have been used in databases a second
problem is what has been called
approximate query processing and this
comes from the work of hellerstein and
Hast actually with very influential work
and the idea here is uh for example
think out that now the task is to
compute the following aggregate query is
the previous uh join query but now we
want to count the number of tabs right
and I'm going to be using this notation
you can think of this in SQL for example
right so obviously it's not a good
strategy to solve this task by first
Computing the answer to this query and
then counting right so what you could
try to do here is you could try to
approximate the answer by doing a
cardinality image right and if you do
that you you could think okay why don't
we do this for other kind of queries for
example the query that's computed this
the sum in the D attribute for the
average on the eight attribute so what
you would like to do here yeah
will you be talking about counting under
set or back semantics and there's yeah
this is under set semantics yeah
understood semantics yeah another
problem will be yeah under that
semantics
yes
um
and it's something that you would like
to do here if you are going to produce
an estimate and you are going to give
this as an answer to the user it's also
to give a confidence interval right to
tell to the user I know that I'm in my
estimate of the count is I don't know
1000 and this is in between this range
with this probability and this is what
people I mean the the hairless thing
that has were thinking when they were
developing this this kind of system so
it's very interesting because then you
you need to think about what kind of
guarantees can be offered about the
results of these approximations and how
can such guarantees be be obtained right
so again sampling will play an important
role here and the third problem is query
exploration so in this case uh the
motivation is that the answer to a query
can be very large if you do a join and
you have one million tuples in the
answer actually giving one million
tuples to the user is not very useful
right nobody is going to check one
million tuples so in that case actually
it could be better to provide some
information about the query to the user
for example could be more informative to
return the number of answers to terms of
the users are 1 million answers or to
enumerate the answer with a polynomial
or constant delay we we so it talk about
that this morning actually this idea
that you have an algorithm that can
produce an answer very fast and then
given an answer can produce the next
answer very fast right eventually with
like polynomial or constant delay yeah
so this it could be very useful you can
say to the user here you have your first
10 answers and if you want more answers
then you can produce this more answer
very fast the next 10 answers but one
problem with this and actually you could
see this this morning is that usually to
do this you need to produce some data
structure that is going to be a compact
representation of the answers right so
and when you want to produce the next
answer what you do is you in that
compact representation actually you try
to construct the next answer so what did
happen in practice is that this answer
tend to be very similar right because
you are in this compact structure so I
mean if you start asking for more more
answers and these answers are all very
similar this is not very useful so a
third problem that is very relevant here
is generate an answer uniformly
Advantage right this could be also very
very useful when you are thinking about
these problems
and
so returning the number of fancy to a
query can be solved Again by using
cardinality estimation or where again
the same problems and Cardinal
estimation can also help to generate at
random and answer to a query and and
here I mean there are questions that we
like to solve so for example can be
sample with uniform distribution really
from all the answer to this query we
want to produce an answer with unimport
distribution or can sampling be used for
cardinality estimation for example yeah
so this is the kind of questions I would
like to answer and what do these
problems have in common well sampling
plays a central role in the development
Solutions or partial solution to this
problems
okay so let me talk a bit about the
complexity of counting and uniform
generation and
I will be showing why these products are
difficult these are not very surprising
results but some of the reductions can
be or are cute and this week we had many
reductions something I enjoyed very much
it's like doing reductions and learning
about reductions so I will provide two
reductions right so let me show you
something very simple and then we will
see if one that is a bit more
complicated the first one is that we
want to do counting right so and the
first priority will be to count the
number of answers to a joint query by
John query I mean a query just with
joins right no selection no projection
just just join so these problems should
be complete this is well known it's very
easy to prove I just want to show you
because it's a simple reduction I mean
it can be obtained for for example from
the program of counting the number of
three colorings of a graph right that
problem can be reduced to the problem of
counting the number of answers to a
joint query and the reduction is very
simple suppose that we have this graph
right and for this graph we want to
count the number of three coloring what
we do is we represent this by using a a
conjective variable it's a query just
with joints actually it's just a query
where we encode it each Edge in the
graph so we have variable X1 to
represent the node one variable two X2
to represent the node two and then what
we say is well X1 is connected with X2
X2 with three three with four four with
one and also we had four with two right
we are just representing the graph so
once we have that actually let's call
this our query and notice here that we
don't have projection so I mean we want
to Output all the variables right so
when we evaluate the query over the
following database what we are going to
obtain is all the three colors what we
are doing here is very simple right
we're just saying we have three colors
this is what we have in the database and
when we take an edge what we have to do
is evaluate this or try to find values
for X1 and X2 such that you you are in
this table so essentially you are saying
okay we have to I have to assign a value
to X1 which is its color I have to
assign a value to X2 which is its color
right and this color had to be different
because here I only have tuples with
different values right and when you do
this in a consistent way in the sense
that now you have a value for X2 a color
then you have to use the same one here
you end up constructing a three coloring
for for the graph right
so on the number of of three colors in
this case will be the number of answers
to this Square every single reduction
yeah
in the query size yeah yes it's in the
query side if you consider data
complexity if the query is fixed the
number of answers polynomial right so
then you you will be able to do count
yeah and query size this is a good point
actually because the query is quite
complicated right yeah in practice you
are not going to have a large query that
represents a graph right and the size of
your database is constant yeah in the
size of the database isn't it extreme
yeah yeah yeah yeah but if the size of
the query speaks actually you will not
be able to trigger yourself right
yeah okay so uh so this is this is this
is hard and and this has a consequence a
very simple one but what it tells us
immediately is that there is no
randomized polynomial time algorithm for
uniform generation of the answer to a
joint query unless NP is equal to to our
P right so uh what it tells us is the
following and this is a simple query of
of the of the previous result so if such
an algorithm exists so if we have a a an
algorithm to uh generate a uniformly at
random uh answer to a joint query in
polynomial time then what we are going
to have is this fully polynomial
randomized approximation scheme right
for the problem of counting the number
of answers to a joint query this is by
the famous work of Jeremy and ambassy
Rani and what this tells us is that uh
that then what you can conclude is that
there is a BPP algorithm uh for the
problem of verifying whether a joint
query has a non-empty set of answers
right so you get an efficient polynomial
time algorithm for the problem of
verifying whether the John query has a
non-empty set of answers and you know
that this is not possible right because
the the program very fine where the
joint query has a non-empty set of
answer is anti-complete and this comes
from the previous reduction right in the
previous reduction if you're asking
where there is a solution for the query
you're asking where it is there is a
three coloring right
so I'm from these actually uh you
obtained that then and P will be
contained in bbp and then in P is equal
torp I mean not that very important
actually the classes the important thing
is that you will be breaking a
complexity assumption that is widely
Vivid right
exactly um uniform generation of answers
at random actually you you have a a join
suppose that the joint has n tacos right
I mean in the answer so you want to
generate that happens with probability
one divided by it yeah
yep
allow for non-uniform uh generation of
solutions oh yeah okay good question if
you are allowed almost uniform
generation in the sense that the
probability will not be one divided by n
but one divided by n plus minus Delta
then the same thing probably holds here
right but if you change that yeah then
then you will not have the hypothesis
from this yeah
okay but this is this is a simple
observation the only thing that I'm
saying here is a uniform generation is
going to be hard in this case
Okay so how can you get we get better
complexity well we rely on something
that we have seen the entire week which
is acidic queries right and a secret
queries are also going to play an
important role here so uh or well a
cyclic query or a class of queries with
the bounded degree of a Simplicity right
such as boundary width or boundary hyper
two width right so in this case you will
be to you you will be able to do
counting and uniform generation
okay let me show you how you do counting
I think I mean if you're going to learn
something today if you haven't seen this
before there is a simple way to do it
actually probably you can imagine at
this point how you will count the number
of answers but before and once I'm going
to mention the triangle query right so
the triangle query we know we know that
it's not a cyclic and the reason is that
a Simplicity is equivalent to
constructing this joint tree right it's
a tree where you expect one property and
the problem is that if you take every
attribute the what you should induce by
just considering this attribute is a is
a subtree right it should be connected
which is not the case here if I consider
the attribute a then this and and I just
take the the substructure of this tree
that that contains this attribute a
we're going to generate these two
isolated nodes here right so it doesn't
satisfy this this joint condition
okay so this is not an acyclic query but
here we have an acyclic query a larger
one right and this is the The Joint tree
for this acid liquid so we're going to
do counting here I mean if you learn
something with the today would be how to
do this if you haven't seen this before
okay and notice that here for example if
I take the variable a this induces a
subtree so it's it's connected right
okay so let me show you how you do how
you do counting any idea how you do this
yeah so are you doing exact counting or
exactly yeah
yeah exactly actually what you do is you
can think that you have well these are
the relations these are the joint tree
and what we're going to do is we're
starting we say well in this case we
know that we have I mean these tablets
appear only once right so you have your
starting point and then you keep going
up so then you say okay what do we know
then for these doubles actually well we
are doing the join here on the variable
sync we have the Tuple for one right and
this is going to be joined with the
Tuple or can be drawn with the top of
one three six and with the second tower
right so if we do this joint we're going
to produce two tablets right and for the
tables five two if we do the join we can
produce one double and for three since
we have value three here three doesn't
appear in the First Column of U we're
going to have zero tabs right so you
have computed that information and the
important thing is that when you keep
going in this stream you just need to
remember these numbers here so you don't
need to remember the rest of the
variables that you have there right and
why is that for example you would say
okay but I should remember F because I
can use it here right but the important
thing is that if f is mentioned here and
it's mentioned here it has to be
mentioned here right because you have
something that is connected right so
this value should be considered there
and there is no problem you will do the
job right so and you keep going like
that right so for example here we know
that all the values are going to be one
right and then you consider this one
here which is a a in this case I mean
you have to consider every child right
so you can see here the first one here
and you say okay for the table for six
uh we're doing the join on four so four
you have two tuples here so we'll say
okay we're going to produce two tuples
for five seven we are going to produce
one table because we have one Tuple here
and then you can see that the second the
second uh child right and for the second
child you say well we are going to to
we're going to get a here's three tuples
we have because value four has been
mentioned three times for the value five
we're going to obtain two tuples because
it has been mentioned twice right and
then you have to do the multiplication
right and notice that this works again
because you cannot have a variable here
and a variable here that is not
mentioned here right it doesn't import
and condition right so and at the end
you will say okay we have six and two
tuples and the number of tuples is in
total is eight right
so you can you can count actually if you
have a a a a joint trick so is this
clear yeah yeah
okay so the second thing that is
important is that you can do the uniform
generation in the cyclic case yeah
make something yeah in fact you can
replace this accounting it's just plus
times yeah you can replace with any same
meaning and the same thing works yeah
executive factorizing the same yeah
actually probably the second thing also
works actually right yeah so now we want
to do uniform generation I want to show
you in this case you can't do uniform
generation efficiently and the idea here
is very simple right you are just going
to use this number to say what are the
probabilities generated double right so
essentially what you're saying okay we
are going to generate a tuple right we
want to generate this with uniform
distribution
uh so the answer in this case has eight
answers sorry the the answer has eight
tuples so you want to generate tuples
with probability one over eight right
that's what you need to do and what you
do is very simple you say okay I have to
pick one of these two and I will do it
with the probability that is
proportional to the number of tuples
that's a simple very simple idea right
so we say it's six over eight two over
eight let's assume that we pick this
double here right so we pick the values
four and six and we have a probability
of three over four here right and then
we have to do it here and here same
thing since we pick value four we we we
know that we can pick either this Tuple
or this Tuple here right we have to do
the join and we have uh in total two
tuples and we have value zeros and two
well you have to pick this with
probability one right
so we have this value here and then you
keep going here again you have value you
have value one here you have two tuples
with value one you can pick one of the
two with probably the one half and
that's what you do here right you you
pick that Tuple and you get these values
here and finally the same thing here
right like since we have value four we
have three tuples we have a provided one
over three and this is the final element
that I don't know you pick this one here
you construct this table and this will
be the probability which is one divided
by n yeah
sorry sorry which one
yeah this one yeah because you have
eight in total right remember you have
eight tuples right yeah yeah so I mean
it's the sum of these two right
that are possible but I mean that
requires to to count first right you
have discounting actually yeah you know
that this you you know these values
actually the answer right and once you
have this counting you can do the
uniform duration right you count first
and then you do the uniform duration
right
that's a good question actually uh
I don't know I don't know actually I
mean
probably you will be relying on some
form of counting actually I mean this is
really like if you don't want to do any
form of counting I don't know how you
can do it
okay so in the basically case you can do
these things uh very efficiently right
but now
the question is does this work with
other operators uh well the previous
approach for a cyclic queries can be
extended to consider the selection
operator is not the problem the
selection just remove some tuples in
some relations
but the tricky question is uh what
happened with projection and with
projection it doesn't work everything
breaks actually with the projection
and let me show you the reduction this
is from Ranger
it's a nice reduction simple reduction
that shows that if you add projection
and you have a cyclic queries uh then
the problem is going to be Sharpie
complete again right and
even even if you just consider a single
existential quantifier so I mean it's
it's a it's a very somehow strong
reduction so here the problem that we
are going to reduce is the following so
uh we have a Viper type graph and we are
we would like to count the number of
Perfect matchings Right remember that
perfect matching here so we have the
same number of notes in the left hand
side and the right hand side the perfect
matching is just a bijection right
and what is well known is that the
problem of counting the number of
perfect machines in a piper Digraph is a
sharply complete problem right so we
like to reduce that problem to the
problem of counting the number of
answers to an acyclic conjunctive query
so a cyclic query that contains
projection right that's the reduction
that we like to do okay so how do we do
this we do the following we represent
our graph in the following way in the
relation i1 we are going to have the
alternative for the node one so we're
going to construct now it's going to be
different from the previous situation
really the database is going to depend
on the graph and actually the number of
relation is going to depend on the graph
right so we have a first relation where
we say well for node one we have two
Alternatives four and five right it's
connected with this for node two we have
three Alternatives because we can
connect with four five and six right and
for node three we just have one
alternative which is six okay
very simple and we are going to have one
extra relation call it these things that
is just for the nodes that we have in
the right hand side the distinct
relation the inequality so we are saying
okay we have four five and six and we
are we put here all the the combination
that tells you that these are different
and what I'm saying is 4 is different
from five five four is different from
six five is different from four etcetera
right we have the distinct relation
there okay
okay so once you have this what you're
going to do is the following you are
going first suppose that we have this
query right this F this F just say i1 of
X1 I2 X2 I3 of x3 what this square is
Computing and it's called f because of
function is just Computing a function
from the the left hand side to the right
hand side just saying in X1 I'm going to
store the image of Node 1 in X2 the
image of node 2 and X3 the image on of
node three just that actually it's not
saying that it's a perfect match and
it's just that it's the image that we
have okay so this is the first query so
now the the query that will do the magic
and just with one existential quantifier
so the idea here is and this WS of is
for wrong we are trying to here to
capture the
um
the functions that we construct with
this F that are wrong right that are not
perfect matching and the way to do this
is the following you say okay what we
have here is first well the first query
that tells you that X1 X2 X3 represents
one of this function and you are saying
that this is not a perfect matching
because there exists a y such that y's
appear in the D relation which means
that Y is one of the nodes in the right
hand side and Y is different from X1
from X2 and from X3 right so why it's an
element from the right hand side which
is different from the images that we
construct here so why it's not covered
this could not be a perfect match yeah
say that uh economics 2x3 has to be
distinct I mean yeah
instead of tourist activity
oh I've been included as relationships
but you have already had tea so they
already encodes this thickness to you
but yeah but that is you say this thing
that's why it's two or three what you're
saying is that this is a correct
perspective
imagine right okay yeah
and okay is that correct yeah yeah and
it will be a correct Magic
so you don't have to add additional
Studio jointly I mean you cannot simply
throwing inequality sensation
no longer fully independent
yeah yeah ah great thank you very much I
was worried that I did it wrong okay the
query has to be sickly right thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
I was thinking about why okay okay let
me let me summarize it just in case you
didn't understand okay this is a
proposal for the query right and this
query is a Civic this is an important
thing and the reason is okay let me show
you this is a joint tree for this square
right so we start with this dx1y and
just here we have X1 and notice that
this generates this part here only right
and same thing here and same thing same
thing here right so this is a joint
three this is an it's an Asic League
query Dan was proposing a query without
existential quantifier but but but it
was a cyclic query right it's a
different situation here we want to do
the reduction to acyclic queries thanks
for not in that sorry
now it's clear yeah okay so and the
important thing here is the following so
you have here this F that tells you
about all the functions W that tells you
about these functions that are not
um a um perfect matching and if you were
able to compute the number of tuples
actually that satisfy this query and
this query you were able to compute the
number of perfect matches and the way
that you do this is by doing this
abstraction right you first compute the
answer to this and then you compute the
answer to this right if you were able to
do this in polynomial time you can do
both and then you can do the the
subtraction right
yeah
it should depend on it
has to be expression complexity yeah
yeah
because it's not fixed actually the
number of the number of relations that
we have here depends on the size of the
query range yeah
are awake we prepared this actually
so I mean you see yeah actually also the
disjunction here because it's X1 X2 X3
depends on the size of the database and
these are all the notes in the left hand
side right
yeah
so if you were able to compute the
answer to this queries then you can
compute the difference and you will
obtain the number of perfect matches
right so you see then that just by
adding one existential quantification
the problem gets much harder right yeah
yeah
[Music]
okay let me I will tell you that in a
second one thing that is important is
exactly that question does this rule out
a fishing uniform generation no actually
the situation is different here because
remember in previous case we were
relying on the fact that if you take the
associate decision problem was difficult
right if you want to count the number of
answers to a joint query is a difficult
problem and the decision problem that is
associated to this which is where you
have at least one answer right where the
the value of the function is greater
than zero you have the the the set of
fancy is not empty it's also a hard
problem it's empty complete right but in
this case it's different right you know
that the the the the uh counting problem
is hard because of this reduction but
the decision problem which is a problem
very fine whether an acyclic query has
an answer it's a problem that can be
solved in polynomial time so this is one
of the problems that is in Sharpie right
that has an easy decision problem that
essentially the reason why hfp is an
interesting class right like if you want
to count the number of
so it could be the case that there is
actually a good approximation algorithm
for dental conjunctive words right
okay so this is sort of the motivation
here and and one thing that is important
for practical applications we need to
consider both acyclic and cyclic queries
we cannot just say we're first for the
basically case we know how to do it we
don't know how to do it in a single case
now I'm we need to come up with solution
in both cases we need to do cardinality
estimation we need to do this kind of
things
uh we need to include all relationality
operators so far I have talked about uh
conjunction uh sorry uh join selection
and projection actually but there are
many more actually
and we need to consider also aggregation
aggregation what I showed you at the
beginning are very common queries right
like take compute the sum compute the
average actually
okay so with this actually this with
this I will start the first part of the
tutorial which is
I'm going to consider joint selection
and aggregation no projection because
projection makes things much more
complicated right so I'm going to tell
you about some techniques I don't know
how many I have until three so I have 25
minutes I mean some techniques to deal
with this problem and then we will move
to the case with projection in the
second part we are going to add
projection and we are going to see how
to deal with with that
okay so a bit of notation just a couple
of things that I don't want to forget to
mention we are going to be using this
Dom of a for the domain of an attribute
usually like natural numbers
uh given a double r and an attribute a
you're going to see this a lot in the
slides when we say r with this notation
we we mean the value of attribute a for
this double the usual notation
I'm going to use this still denotation
to say that R is compatible with s which
means that remember that here we have
tuples and we have attributes with name
what it means that these two tuples have
the same values in their common
attribute this is very relevant because
we will be Computing this semi join
operator all the time remember the semi
join is all the tuples for from R such
that there exists are Tuple in s that is
a a
consistent with this Double R right
which is the same as saying okay
probably the definition that you know
right it's the same as saying that if x
is the attribute of R to compute the
semi-joint of R and S what you do is you
complete the join first so you get that
all the the tuples that are compatible
and then you do the projection over R
right so you are reducing the number of
R by considering the tuples that are
consistent with the table in s right
very very we will be using same joints I
mean all the presentations very useful
okay so let's start with uniform
generation how can you do uniform
generation in the case where we have
selection print sorry join join is the
main operation right Aggregates and and
and
selection okay
okay so uh let me start with sampling
with uniform distribution and an ability
of History here
um the ideas that we are going to to see
are from uh alkins uh thesis here the UC
Berkeley actually he was talking about
something for databases a long time ago
actually and then you see that there I
mean these techniques have been used
actually but like like uh probably the
the the the the the the next paper the
following paper after that were these
ideas were really used is paper by that
hoodie and moduani actually where they
were really trying to understand what
can you do if you do some pretty much
right so and and so the idea that I'm
going to show you here actually some of
them are coming from from these papers I
mean all these citations are in the
presentation at the end right so okay so
the idea here is that we would like to
generate uniformly at random metabol in
the join of these two relations right
and ideally the probability of choosing
this double should be one divided by the
number of answers I mean I want uniform
generation but what it could happen is
that the probability is still the same
for all the tuples but you have a
probability for example of rejecting
right I mean in some cases you are not
going to produce a tap right so it could
be the case that the probability is
small
okay so the first uh the simplest way to
do this is is the following uh just
generate uniformly of random a table
from R I'm assuming that you can do that
right
and then just generate uniformly and
random tablet from s and and and if
these two tuples are compatible then
return this I will be using this
notation just to emphasize that these
are the component right if you want to
produce a tuple in the joint you will do
the join of the tuples right but I'm
just saying these two components are s
this is what you are going to return
yeah so uh so this problem we already
know how to solve right because the
cyclical equations are you no no no I'm
I'm in the general case right but you're
doing one joint right oh yeah okay so so
is this you are going to kill my example
no no
that's a that's a good question okay
several comments to that question
actually
uh first comment the techniques that we
are going to use here they're going to
we are going to generalize them to an
arbitrary number of jobs right this is
like the simplest example and the second
thing that is more important is that
even if we know how to do it for the
secret case at your right we have just
two relations you want to do it faster
right you in in practice you you will
uh
you would like to
get an estimation of that cardinality
much faster than the time that you need
to compute actually or to to compute I
mean the size of this joint right by
using this algorithm right so even in
the secret case what I'm trying to say
is that you want to do it much faster
than the algorithm that I show you
actually right so you're assuming some
kind of Index right yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah definitely yeah
yep anymore
yeah so this is the simplest way to do
this immediately you will see that
obviously the uh you get the uh a uh
algorithm that samples with uniform
distribution and actually if if I is
compatible with this the probability of
being generate is one divided by the
size of R times the size of X right so
so you you get uniform distribution but
you don't get the one divided by the
size of the joint I mean this is very
simple uh and and the probability is
that the Tuple is generated actually is
going to be well the size of the joint
divided by the side of this product
which at the end tells you that if the
join is is a small right if you just
have a few tuples in the join
this probability can be very small and
you are not going to generate anything
right so this is not really a good
technique that's the only message for
for this right
um
before they
any more questions no yeah
before they attack the I mean that's
that's not a good technique right yeah
okay so to produce a sample you can do a
different thing you can do the following
you can generate uniformly and random a
tuple from R then you could say Okay
since I generate this Tuple let's
generate a tuple from the double that
can be joined with this right so that's
what you are saying here you say take
let's take X
let's take the uh the or let's select
all the tablet from s where the value of
the attribute B is the same as the value
of additive would be in the Tuple R so
we just restrict to the Tuple that can
be joined with this R and then let's do
uh let's select uniformly at random
attackable from this set right very
simple idea and return this taboo yeah
so this this works actually uh but the
the problem that we have in this case is
that is that the tuples are not
generated uniformly so if you think
about what is the probability of
generating this RS is going to be the
probability of well that R is generated
and the probability that this is
generated given that R is generated
right and this is going to be well the
probability of that R is generated is
just uniform distribution what divided
by size of R but then you are saying
well what is the probability of s being
generated well in this case uh given
that I selected R the number of tuples
that I have that that can be joined with
with r is this is the size of this
relation right you do s semi join R so
all the tables that are consistent with
this Double R and then you are saying
I'm going to select with uniform
distribution from here right
again you have a problem here it's not
going to be uniform distribution okay so
let me tell you about the okay and and
what is the problem with this obviously
we have a problem here because if we
have a value like this value to here
that appears only once the probability
of sampling this is going to be much
larger right so if you start with if you
select this double one two which is
going to be with probability one half
right then you will have to select this
double here so the whole probability of
this Tuple here is one half but if you
start from the table three four which
has probability one half here you have a
probability of one divided by n y Over N
to select one of these Tuple so the
probability of this combination here is
one is going to be one over two n right
so you have a much smaller probability
okay so how do we solve this problem and
now I will tell you about the simple
idea that is proposing this all can and
probably was known for a long time
actually in many different contexts
which is the idea and this is the same
that we'll be using once and again
actually this is the idea of like let's
try to correct the error that we are
producing when we are sampling right
it's very simple idea that's the whole
thing that we want to do
so how it works is is as follows
actually you say generate uniformly and
random a double r in R right and then
you are going to have a probability of
rejection of not producing anything and
this probability of rejection is going
to be this one it's going to be one
minus you say Okay up first sorry I
forgot to say something so let's define
first this quantity this m sub B of s
which is is the following actually you
say okay for every possible value in the
domain of D count how many tables you
have for that value in relation s right
so for for and then once you have that
compute the maximum so what I'm saying
for Value three I have I don't know four
tuples for Value five I have seven
tuples for Value one I have the two
tapos then this number is going to be
seven this is a maximum number of tuples
that have the same value in the as you
would be sorry I forgot to say that so
then to produce a sample what you do is
something very simple you generate
uniformly and random at Apple R in in R
then you reject with probability one
minus the size I mean that the size of
what you are going to produce right
because this is s semi joint R all the
table formats that are consistent with
are divided by this maximum size right
notice that then what you are doing is
for doubles that
such that this value is small you are
you're having a larger probability of
rejecting right so you think about the
previous example for this value 2 where
we have only one Tuple in the S relation
right this probability is going to be
very high compared to the tuples that we
have that have uh like the double with
the other value that where many tablets
that have this common body right
okay and once you have rejected with
this probability what you do is you
generate uniformly on random a tuple s
in this tapos in s that are consistent
with r right very simple
and then why this work it's uh and you
return RS right why this work again it's
very simple to compute this to see why
this works actually what is it if R is
consistent with s what is the
probability of generating this element
is the probability of generating R and
then the probability of generating s
given that you generated generate uh
generated R and this is well let's look
at the probabilities the probability of
generating R is one divided by the size
of R right then you have to accept you
cannot reject to continue with the
process and the probability of accepting
is this probability here is remember is
this s the size of s semi join are the
size of the set of tables that are
consistent with r divided by this this
bound that we have this MB right and B
of s sorry here I'm missing an S there
is a typo there and then once you have
done that then you sample from the
tables that are consistent with r with
uniform distribution so what you're
going to get is one divided by the size
of s semi joint I right so and the magic
here is that you are going to simplify
the this term here actually right that
depends on the in the in the in the on
the table R so I'm going to obtain at
the end actually is the probability is y
divided by size of R times N Sub B of s
okay so very simple actually
so what you are getting here is actually
what you are using here is an upper
Bound for the size uh sorry it's an
upper Bound for the size of the join of
R and S yeah
it's a very simple idea actually
okay so how do you generalize this uh
okay so let me talk about this uh
framework that was developed by by kg
yeah yeah
another type of
um value would also be useful because if
s has a lot of tuples with you know
small ranges of B and one massive one
you will end up wasting a lot of
computation or and and if you knew that
it would be better to to sample from s
and then do this on R so if if you knew
sort of the the the a better
distribution of the ranges and the two
relations you can decide which one to
sample from
yeah yeah and and actually one of the
yeah I totally agree and one of the nice
thing about this framework is that this
framework you will going to ask for an
estimation that only has needs to have
some properties so if you have an
estimation they have that property it
can be used here so you could replace
for example this estimation here
for the size of the joint by another
estimation that is better right as long
as this estimation satisfies some
properties actually in that sense what
I'm going to show is like a
generalization of this but also is a
general framework to do some signature
so you could do exactly what you're
saying actually you have better
estimations you go to place this
estimation but by those estimations
right
so myself
it is uniform right uniform in the sense
that is this for if R is compatible with
s the probability is exactly the same
right this remember that this quantity
depends only on S it doesn't depend on
the tuples right
yeah that's what I was saying okay we
want uniform distribution in the sense
that the probability for all the tablets
will be the same but we have a
probability of rejection actually but we
cannot avoid assumption right so that's
what I was saying at the beginning that
ideally
okay
yeah that's what I was saying ideally
the probability should be this one
actually but what is going to happen is
that in practice we are not going to
have that the probability has to be the
same for all the tablet as important
things but it will be smaller than this
quantity right because we're just going
to have we're going to have a
probability of rejecting tables right
yes and just try again yeah exactly you
can try it again yeah yeah definitely
yeah that's what you are going to do
actually right so I was also trying to
understand so the the first algorithm
that you showed
users the more powerful assumption that
you can do weighted sampling
then you can sample with high
probability the topics that you know
will occur more often in their answer of
the joint so now you're removing that
assumption so you're allowing yourself
to do only uniform something over the
tables and you still want to get this uh
uniform as a result which is a universe
sample from the entire join and the
trick is to to use the rejection
sampling in order to recover uniformity
yes
okay good
okay so let me come back
is this the best you can do without
access to accounts
the thing is that I mean if you go to
the research question which has a debate
and we're going to see that there is no
like in general still you which you can
rely actually right like or or lower
bound that tells you things like that
actually we're really missing these
things actually right yeah no I don't
know I don't know whether this is
you need some access to some counts to
know the probability from which you have
to be late
the thing is that I suppose that this is
similar to what Virginia was saying it's
like kind of difficult to define whether
you need to have access or not have
access to come right uh it's like you
pick the
yeah
no but these are these are counts that
are perilation whereas the algorithm
needs account that is global okay right
because you need to filter then correct
the results that's the difference okay
and these are statistics that are super
easy yeah you would say Excel that's a
good way to put it that you need local
count actually which is something that
you have you have a statistic about the
relation right so this this quantity
ends up B of s is a quantity that you
usually have in practice but not
something low on right
okay so let me show you okay I'm quite
late actually so okay let me show you
this General framework for example
probably I'm going to move some part of
the materials from the first part to the
second part actually otherwise I'm not
going to show you which thing all we're
going to stick to stay until later okay
so let me show you how to generalize
this it's very simple actually first
let's consider this path query right
this is an acyclic query but it's it's I
mean it's a path actually if you think
about the three joint tree right
so okay so what you would like to have
in practice right or what you would like
to have actually if you have access to
Counting is something like this Define
this quantity W of t as do the join of
this Tuple t with the other relations
right so you have exact counting in this
case so if you have access to Discount
that this this quantities then you will
be able to do uniform generation exactly
as we showed before and also well if
Define the W of a relation just as the
sum of the the Ws of t for each Tuple in
the relation right
okay so one important thing about this W
is this W satisfy this condition here
I'm going to show you why but it's very
simple is that W of T right remember
this is I'm assuming that t is in R sub
I so I'm what I'm doing here is the join
of t with r sub I plus 1 R sub I plus
two up to R sub n so I'm saying is okay
this is the same as doing W where I take
R sub I plus 1 and I do the semi join
with this Double T I'm doing the
restriction and notice that this depends
on the following right so if we say what
is the definition of this W of T it's
going to be the sum here so I'm what I'm
saying is okay take all the T primes in
R sub I plus 1 and do this join here
right just this just definition so and
essentially well you have to keep the
tuples and T primes that are compatible
with t right otherwise it's not going to
produce any tuples but the key issue is
that now what you would like to say is I
I no longer need this T right and the
important thing here is that if you
remove this T you could say okay but
what how many we have some values here
that contradict some of the values that
we have here well that's not possible
because this query is a signification
it's a path so if you have a variable
that is mentioned here and here it has
to be mentioned here right so if you are
compatible with this one you will become
so if you are not compatible with this
one here with the double here you will
not be compatible here right so again
this is a very important property you
can remove this T and then you have this
uh then you have well what we call W of
T Prime so you're saying for every D
Prime in the semi join we do W of T
Prime and this is exactly the definition
of w of this semi-joint why is this
important because now we are going to
talk about these three actions that we
need for the for the estimates of the
size of the of the of this uh joins
actually so we are not going to use this
W of T because we don't have access to
this form of counting but we are going
to assume is the following so we we
don't have access to this WT right
because this will be the same as
counting what we're going to have is an
approximation W of this W here right and
for this approximation we have we asked
for three conditions right the first
condition is this this is an over
approximation the W of T is always the
this W is always greater than this
lowercase style right the second
condition is that for the if you think
about the last relation this W of T is
going to be equal to one you don't have
to join with anything it's just a tuple
right so you expect this this W here
also to satisfy the same condition right
and the third one and this is related
and this is why I was showing this
previous property right uh the third one
is this one here actually you expect
that that this WFT is greater or equal
than the W of this semi joint here for
the case of lowercase w they were equal
right here you expect this to be greater
than this one and this is very
interesting and it's related with some
of the queries that you were asking for
example if you take W as the AGM bound
the AGM bound satisfy these properties
and in particular satisfy this one here
because of it can be proved by using the
query decomposition Lemma right so it's
very interesting because you would say
okay I'm not going to use the previous
Mount I'm going to use a bound that I
know that is better and it's still going
to to work in this case
okay so let me finish with with this so
the to produce a sample you do exactly
what you were doing before right so you
will generate a probability but now what
you have is this estimate here right so
you will say w of R1 divided by this
value of R1 right before actually you
you were using this this okay I will
show you in a second that this is
generalization actually but before you
were using directly this this step
so then what you do from for I equal to
2 to n is just the same that we were
doing before you are going to reject
with some probability right which is
proportional to this quantity for the
semi-joint divided by what I produced in
the previous step
and then if you this she decided to
accept and you continue you are going to
generate the Tuple from this semi-join
right so you have to do it from the
semi-jump because you are saying I
already restricted by using R so by
minus one right so now I have to
generate something that is consistent
with this and you will do it with this
probability here right and at the end
you are going to return this this Tuple
here so let me show you why why this
code is is very simple so suppose that
let's first consider the case of uh what
is the probability that R1 R2 is
generated is going to be the probability
that one is generated times the
probability there are two generated
given that one R1 is generated and this
is going to be the following so you
start from this well W of R1 divided by
W of R1 right
and you do this because of this first
step that says well the first Apple you
have to generate with this probability
then you'll have to accept not reject
and you do this with this probability
right immediately see that you are going
to simplify these terms here right and
then okay because of this term and then
you say okay I'm going to generate R2
and you are doing this by using this
step in the algorithm which and the
probability was W for two divided by by
this right and notice that this
probabilities are well defined for
example
in in all the terms that that we have
here in particular for example this one
here is well defined because we have an
action that says that this quantity has
to be smaller than this quantity here
right
okay and and here actually you will
similarly you are going to simplify
these terms here right and this is what
you obtain as the probability this still
depends on R2 so if we do this for all
the and you can prove this by induction
the same thing for R1 to our n what you
are going to generate is this but now
you know that W of R sub n has to be
equal to 1 right so and at the end this
is the probability that you get 1
divided but W of R sub yeah one right
which is the same probability for all
the tables although it's not exactly the
size of the joint
I notice that again that if you have a
better estimation this probability is
going to be higher actually which is
something that you want
okay so this is a generalization of the
previous idea and why is why is that
actually you could I mean if you want to
use the estimates that we were using
before remember that this m sub a sub 2
of R2 what it means is okay you for the
atibody2 remember R2 has adios A2 I3 for
the rto2 you consider the different
values that you have there you count the
number of tables that have that value
and you compute the maximum right so
this you could say is the estimate for
this wr1 this is the same how many times
with how many tables can I join well
this is an estimate right because this
is a maximum number of tuples that have
the same attribute the same value in A2
right so it's an estimate on the number
of double that that this R1 could join
with right W of R2 has to be equal to
one right this is part of the actions
that we have and then well if you think
about W of well this uppercase R1 it's
going to be the sum of this W of T which
is the sum of these values here which is
this quantity here I'm just mentioning
this because then when you do w for two
the sum of this W of Steed all of these
are one so you're going to get this one
so then when you do this probably the R1
R2 is generated you are going to have
this expression here this is what I
showed you before and then immediately
what you see is well W of R1 is this
quantity here
right W of sorry of this W of R1 is
going to be this quantity here right
then you have this WS here that are
going to be equal to this quantity and
this one is one if you simplify also
this m this term here where you are
going to get is this one which is
exactly the expression that you have for
this all uh algorithm right so so it it
essentially what is telling you the the
you were using this this values m in
that case actually to do the DST image
okay so uh and I would like to mention
this again but you can use better bounce
for example you could say the W of t t
is a table in R sub I it's going to be
the AGM bound of this uh join actually
that we have from R sub I plus 1 to apps
R sub n if you use that bound and you
also say that W of T is equal to one for
the tuples and that are in R sub n you
you can prove that this W satisfy the
three properties that we have before
right in particular because of this
query decomposition level so you could
use this bound actually to do sampling
so as long as you satisfy the the
previous actions you will be used you
will be able to use this this sample
technique
okay so I think it's a good point uh to
a stop actually so it's three right yeah
okay yeah
good questions
do you have any idea of the Practical of
the practicality of this projection
something
yeah I mean it works very well uh
probably the best thing that you do is
take a look to the paper so it's a sigma
paper by KB and collaborators actually
and they have really good results
section in terms of on of estimation and
and the rejection is not high actually
right now it worked very well actually
in the experiments that they did works
very well yeah it was quite a joint yeah
no it's not it's afterwards I mean what
they've done you can think of actually
when they join it's just a common about
when the joint introduce it as an
estimate here because we would say here
random work
but then you don't have exactly the
guarantees because these are estimations
already right it's not a quantity like
the AGM bound protection
sampling
please I was wondering whether it's
possible to bound the total number of
consecutive rejections that would be
able to get on any expectations before
we get
an accepted December and the reason
it seems to me that it's possible for
the join R and S that you explained
earlier it's possible to construct a
database instance
[Applause]
[Music]
and the rejections before we Assemble
yeah that's uh yeah that's a good point
yes it's possible to estimate that and
you are right actually that we need a
large number of attempts before getting
a tuple actually this could not be I
mean in that case it will not be
practical right so essentially what we
usually do in practice is actually you
don't continue sampling you say okay I'm
going to do this number of samples
actually some of them don't work
actually you will have to accept
them so you have like a budget you would
say Okay I want to construct 100 sample
sessions right even if I mean 80 of them
were not troubles in the joint I I still
want to do something with this player
actually and with the information that
the old ones who are not in the journey
um if you had a perfect bat if you just
had the cardinality you can like this
General framework means that you
wouldn't stop right here yeah exactly
yeah as you get down there
yeah
yeah yes
a secret choice
he started his PhD thesis in 78 however
but anyway he's a result for all
basically joins okay including okay
you'll do it in an absolute Optimum
Pages we
must help us
I didn't put any citation in this
algorithm because I don't know I mean
who came up with this idea but this
probably has been known for a long time
yeah there's an original 788
[Music]
I actually want to wake up the uh
yeah yeah I mean the very beginning is
just sampling for a factor graph right
very variable elimination to computer
but uh what I was wondering here is if
you're doing these multiple joints what
feels right to me intuitively is the
sequential Monte Carlo algorithm like a
particle filter where you
you you take a you know a fair wise join
and then you re-weigh your samples
your sub sample and then you do another
drawing you re-wave that seems like you
know that's the appropriate algorithm
for this type actually movement to see
something like that this is one to join
actually yeah yeah yeah definitely I
mean this is one I mean essentially the
the techniques in the area you can
divide it into these techniques that are
trying to do uniform generation and the
other one actually that is not producing
tuples with the uniform distribution but
they're using these horwood Stones some
idea to act which is exactly exciting to
consider this weight section to produce
something that is going to be unbiased
actually right yeah
yes a bit of a different application
scenario where I mean I imagine with
this something you can still get tuples
that are very similar to each other uh
but what happens if you know for some
applications you might need to post that
are diverse so you want to sample
respect to some diversity measure so you
can get back to very diverse tuples
which for instance makes sense for
radiant descent and other such uh
applications do you know of anything in
this space well the work of ranker
actually yeah they have started to work
actually on this idea of
some diversity criteria
yeah but I mean
this is overjoying basically join or
just arbitrary
conditions
the extractability although it gets even
more complicated when you're doing
counting
yes
as you know very well I think this is a
characterization in terms of the
existence of a full reducer which is a
sequence of semi joints and that would
give you personal agreements
a full reducer but what happens if if
the graph if the schema is not as if the
query is not that secret
is there something that you can get out
of approximately full reviews that's a
very good question actually I don't know
actually the the I mean we're going to
be something we're going to say
something
for a cyclic join queries and you will
see that we have to use the structure of
the joint tree actually right but what
you are saying actually could be the
alternative I don't know yeah
all the intermediate results
actually
yeah
yeah exactly
that's a good question actually it looks
like a nice problem okay
okay if there are no no more questions
get your messages